freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge ein tag persönlicher gottes
ist eine ganze weile her dass ihr mich
von einem stativ beobachtet und das hat
einen besonderen grund und den darf ich
jetzt ein video begrüßen eric um gott
also klatschen dass es nicht so traurig
das ist eric deren mann die maschine die
seit mittlerweile zwei monaten diesen
kanal auseinander nimmt also wirklich
ich muss an dieser stelle einfach macht
öffentlichkeit gewandt du hast die
videos und den channel auf ein neues
level gehoben und ihr durch den heute
endlich kennenlernen deshalb bin ich
gespannt also wie bist du auf bring ich
will aufgeregt dass auf sonntag aber ich
meine es wurde viel gerätselt wer ist
der mann hinter der kamera das ist er
ich würd sagen wir fangen aber direkt an
schnell wieder hinter die kamera und wir
legen los - korso hier stehen wir also
es gibt zum frühstück was eric stramm
max stramm max aber auf eine mediterrane
italienische interpretation wir arbeiten
mit getrockneten tomaten summers an
automaten berater gutem olivenöl
sizilianischen landbrot und dazu
natürlich spiegeleier leute das wird
sehr sehr wild ich hab die gewaschen
schneidet hier unten einmal den stil ab
und schneidet sie dann hier so schön in
feine streifen aber die werden nicht
einmal den schmecken er ich möchte auf
jeden fall ganz kritisch sein hat er
schon gesagt wir haben auch einiges an
wählten gerichten vor heute über dieses
frühstück ist wirklich muss schon so
eine sehr sehr gute auswahl getroffen
ist das ist auch eine der wichtigen
sachen immer lieber ich wissen muss er
ist nicht nur sehr gut hinter der kamera
sondern auch sehr gut hinterm herd und
das hilft mir umfasst liegt daran dass
wir einfach beide uns super gut
austauschen können darüber einfach beide
spaß daran haben für das reich und auch
schon wir brauchen gar nicht so super
viel wie packe ich mal eine kleine
schüssel und dann machen wir weiter wir
geben hier auf dem teller und dann
lernen sie natürlich auch schon mal
kräftig salzen berater streichen wir
dann schön auch dass angerostete brot
ich zeige euch mal was wir hier noch
haben zwar nichts geringeres als
griechen-coach otto cocteau und das
gleiche mit parmaschinken noch leute
dass ich nicht sagen heftig und ich habe
auch bewusst dieses gewählt aber ich
liebe touristische küche wo das produkt
zählt das fühle ich allerdings auch
gerade das abendessen ist auch ein sehr
puristisches rezept werde sich da
gewählt habe zeit musst es dir gefallen
so wir haben ein paar gehackte
getrocknete tomaten doch das brot
einfach wunderschön so ein
sizilianisches landbrot leute gibt wenig
besseres brot schneiden und zwar nicht
irgendwie sondern so fingerdicke
scheiben schön aus der mitte dieses
gelbliche das ist natürlich liegen wir
das werden wir gleich mit gutem olivenöl
anrösten soll da noch schiefgehen
griechisches olivenöl richtig dass man
ein gutes zu nutzt dazu geben wir jetzt
ein klein wenig auf beide seiten von
unserem italienischen landwirt.com jung
das wird nichts mit liebe einmassiert
hier gehen wir auch ein bisschen was
rein für unsere auspacken werden gelegen
das brot direkt mal hinein zu
aufschlagen rein mit dem brot kostet an
spiegel ragt aus wir sehen uns gleich
wenn alles fertig ist
[Musik]
der weg ist es auch so weit da sind wir
dann sehen wir nun ja wir haben hier
einen schönen rundes bronze von
sizilianischen landbrot mit frischen
zutaten
das ganze gibt einen strammen max oder
besser gesagt ein stramm maximo weiß ja
was sie machen nur ist es
erstmal
man merkt dass frau kritiker wieder war
da ja da hat einer ein bisschen lange
gebraucht mit dem kamera weißt du was
ich es fühlen würde so einmal durch gold
karten knackigen mittelbar was mich
jetzt schon mal gefällt die rosmarin
note ok hab ich dich egal im letzten
moment der herren setzt da muss schon
sagen also ist ein schöner ansteht ja es
kann eigentlich nur schmecken also da
ist alles drauf was ich liebe ja am pult
man einen mann gemacht den du liebst
den hasen space ich muss sagen eric ich
habe mich selten so ins zeug gelegt
verwischt immer so was kann ich noch
machen der will mich fit ich glaube du
wolltest du es auch wirklich spannend
was wird sagt ich bin auch gespannt was
ich jetzt sage ich das ding ist wie wir
schon zum abhängen gesagt haben so was
ist einfach absolut puristisch jedes
produkt muss gut sein damit das gut ist
weil du kannst ja du hast ja in der
zubereitung wenig verändert an dem
produkt ist das brot vielleicht
angeröstet und du hast das ei an
gerüstet aber die einzelnen tomaten
berater der aufschnitt ist ja wohl wer
kommt musik weil die stimmen da muss es
sein und du hast einfach die richtigen
produkte gekauft dann auch noch das brot
akzeptabel
erst wollte ich habe es auch
komponist war wirklich außen wie innen
sword so wie es sein muss das wachstum
ich möchte dich mit
deinen tipp du hast recht man darf nicht
immer nur auf die positiven dinge im
leben schauen er habe selber gesehen ein
game war leider nicht perfekt aus diesem
grund clustern 50 und 19 tyler machen
dass leute wir sehen uns zum mittagessen
es gibt eine kleine überraschung und
viel spaß dabei so leute kommen wir zum
mittagessen es gibt lammkoteletts mit
persischen reis mit dieser tat die
kruste wert schon mal gegessen hat weiß
es ist unnormal krank und reis ist ein
gutes stichwort ich muss euch nämlich
das beichten leute noch vor 12 monaten
habe ich immer diesen koch preis gemacht
und auch schon als ich meine koch videos
gemacht habe deshalb gab es auch die
reise in meinem leben ich habe nämlich
einfach nicht gecheckt wie man geilen
reis macht und da habe ich mir vor 12
monaten gedacht muss schluss sein ich
habe mir im reiskocher sie kauft von
raich hunger kommt nämlich zum thema und
es hat mein leben verbessert ich sag's
euch ehrlich seitdem kann ich reiße in
gerichte guten gewissens integrieren
weil er einfach immer gut ist und immer
funktioniert also leute das ist das gute
ding erinnert euch vielleicht ich habe
auf den kleineren ich habe jetzt aber
geupdatet einfach wirklich weiß neuss
ist und wie gesagt ich habe mir das ding
gekauft und die sind dann auf mich
zugekommen deshalb könnt ihr mir
wirklich glauben mein wort voll nicht
dass das wirklich gut ist digitaler
reiskocher heißt dieser wunderschöne man
hier vor mir und er hat jede menge
funktionen schnelldurchlauf leute
lescaut standard man macht sich schnell
reis 25 minuten hält acht stunden lang
warm und frisch traum turbo 20 minuten
christi das was wir heute machen die
kreisky noah leute was hier los granges
stil baking das ding kann wirklich viel
und wir zeigen euch das ein szenario was
relativ gut demonstriert was dieser
reiskocher alles kann wir machen nämlich
eben diesen persischen leckeren reis und
im hintergrund wie ihr seht erreichen
alles andere als und hatten jede menge
produkte zu geschickt von denen auch ihr
welche umsonst bekommen könnt das
erklärte jetzt einfach dann seht ihr
auch schon was das ding hier drauf hat
und zwar könnt ihr wenn ihr über meinen
leben in der video beschreibung geht
oder den kreis max benutzt eins von
diesen vier produkten umsonst bekommen
und zwar ab einem mindestbestellwert von
15 euro und das ist wirklich ein guter
deal das heißt ihr müsst keinen reis
vorbestellen ihr könnt auch einfach ein
paar nudeln probieren eine polonaise
oder sonstwas und dann kriegt ihr zum
beispiel acht probierpaket mit
verschiedenen reissorten ihr kriegt eine
bento box mit besteck ihr kriegs- und
meistens reis glas oder eine thai curry
box auf jeden fall dankeschön an rice um
die unterstützung wir machen jetzt einen
geilen christi reist wir haben hier den
inhalt von der big box das sind zwei
sorten reis was marty und andre reiß
sabrina ist ein anschein ein sehr edler
reis aus dem iran das ist ein indischer
reis wir schnappen uns zuallererst aber
zwei esslöffel butter schmalz geben die
in den reis woche hinein machen den
laden zu starten den wärme modus und
schmelzen das ganze jetzt nehmen wir
unseren safran setzt heute sehr edel
verpackt das ganze ist auch einfach
wirklich was feines also eine feine
weise diese panik safran brett sieht so
fragt brett in hot ich habe es leider
ein bisschen hinterher verstehe schon
warum es sinn macht einen mörder zu
haben ich werde daran arbeiten sollte
ich habe hier 600 milliliter wasser wir
nehmen unseren sachfragen und gehen
jetzt ins wasser hinein ihr merkt schon
das ganze wasser nicht direkt farbe an
aber da lösen wir das ganze jetzt noch
mal ein bisschen drin auf und das ist
dann auch das wasser mit dem wir gleich
arbeiten werden aber wenn ich natürlich
gleich heiß waschen dann ist es jetzt
auch endlich soweit wir machen mal den
reiskocher auf umgeschmolzen reis hinein
und unser safran wasser und hier ist
jetzt wirklich wichtig wir kratzen alles
raus was ist hier noch an sagt man gibt
also wollen nichts davon verlieren so
einmal durchführen dann können wir auch
schon zumachen ins menü gehen wohnt wir
wählen den christen modus aus dingen
einfach start der rest von digitalen
reisbacher erledigen kümmern wir uns
also um die lancom was wir für unsere
lammkoteletts brauchen wir brauchen
letzt wäre das gedacht dazu rosmarin
thymian oregano salz pfeffer olivenöl
darin marinieren wir das ganze einfach
nur während unser sachrang reis kocht
und ja das machen wir
schön darüber verteilen
wir setzen jetzt alles mal gleichmäßig
mit unserer marinade sieht gut aus das
riecht gut frische zutaten in jung dass
man nicht gut wird jetzt denken wir das
ganze ab und dann warten wir einfach bis
unser charly kreis fast fertig ist und
solange das marinieren so leute es ist
soweit sind noch 15 minuten auf unserem
reiskocher das heißt wir gehen jetzt
darauf an den grill der schönen
vorgeheizt ist und dagegen jetzt schön
und so lammkoteletts traum leute
minzblätter griechischer joghurt mischen
wir einfach klein mit joghurt dazu was
nicht schon ultra crust würden jetzt
einfach unter und dann sind wir genau
fertig in zwei minuten piepst unser
digitaler reiskocher mithin sie hier
[Musik]
was wird lag damals würden mindestens
genauso lecker glaub ich bitte schneit
da einfach mal mesrine ich will nur
sehen was abgeht
ich mache jetzt einfach mal so in sich
sagt er ich die fahne ist krass das ist
wirklich alles kommt von safran ja aber
0,25 gramm safran ja ok könne wohl birne
ja würde manch einem youtuber sagen
was richtig lecker perfekt gesalzen
jetzt mit dem joghurt noch als gegenpol
erste mal dass ich wirklich mal eine
kruste von reis feier der ich finde die
wirklich dafür gibt es auch einfach mal
rein aber ich liebe
drei viertel sind weg und es war
wirklich kein leichtes ist war eine
schlacht aber ich habe sehr genossen sie
zu schlagen hat nicht schlägst du mich
jetzt nicht hat es geschmeckt groß war
ein fest
und ich wirklich sagen also du hast gut
am frühstück angeschlossen sagte sie was
sagst du also der reihe ist wirklich der
hatte so eine rippe die lammkoteletts
alter wir waren wirklich perfekt also
was heißt das minimum das heißt das sind
komplex grübeln wer will da nicht können
oder nicht können wenn man das so
bewertet dann ist das auf jeden fall
erzählt also ich würde auch reichen von
zehn prozent kommen wir ins geschäft ich
bin gespannt ob ich das noch mal
vielleicht schaffe beim abendessen aber
ihr werdet jetzt in
spaghetti carbonara mit selbst gemachter
pasta guckt euch diesen tisch wir haben
pecorino wir haben gerade wir haben eier
wir haben jetzt das ist wirklich krass
finde ich wenn man sich mal vor augen
führt was eine richtige carbonara alles
rein gehört und da die pasta selbst
machen ein bisschen dauert fangen wir
damit auf an pro person zwei eier und 20
gramm ich benutze hier einfach ein pasta
pizza pasta und davon nehmen wir jetzt
schon das ist auch ein bisschen
glücklich das ist jetzt quasi hart
weizenmehl aber alles funktioniert gut
400 gramm unser mehl geben wir jetzt
einfach auch unser brett vor'm darin
eine coole und darin könnten wir jetzt
unsere eier vermischen aber ich mache
das safety halber einfach in dieser
schüssel so wenn das ganze einigermaßen
verwirrt ist geben wir es einfach in die
mitte in unsere kohle hin ein
problem
das den start seines lebens
vom läuft das denn soll
ja dann sieht das ganze so aus leute es
passiert den besten offensichtlicher
weise probiere das ganze jetzt zu retten
ist war ein kurzer aber harter weg bis
hierher jetzt fahren wir daraus eine
kugel und lassen es dann für 10 15
minuten einfach nur in frischhaltefolie
ruhen hat aber wirklich eine gute
konsistenz bekommt ein spaß
los geht's mit der pasta wird ich habe
mein kleines drama hier wieder
aufgeräumt wir haben hier ganz schale
darf man werden wir ungefähr so 150
gramm brauchen ich glaube das ist
ziemlich genau dieses stück hier wir
nehmen jetzt die kuren schale und
schneiden daraus ja also 34 millimeter
dicke streifen ein teelöffel in
butterschmalz den gehen wir einfach in
unsere fahne hineinlassen ihn schmelzen
und dann könnt ihr auch schon
weitermachen ich habe hier vier eigelb
schon mal vorbereitet jetzt schnappen
wir uns unserem torino und müssen erst
mal reiben sind nehmen unsere mentale
und geben sie in die pfanne und wir
lassen jetzt für ein paar minuten
einfach bei mittlerer hitze ein bisschen
aus also einfach damit dieser gesamte
geschmack aus fleece und dann später von
unseren nudeln aufgenommen wird und
jetzt machen wir uns ein wenig platz
denn jetzt machen wir die frische nudeln
und zwar in echtzeit neben byd weil wir
es verdammt nochmal können und wir
hatten schon einen film
deshalb hoffe ich dass es alles weitere
einigermaßen klar nudelmaschine
festmachen hier so ein tag bei der eine
ganze weile gegangen ist wir benötigen
etwas von unseren mail und wählen unsere
arbeitsfläche großzügig weil das erspart
uns einiges an kopfschmerzen später wir
haben dir in den teig einmal und dann
können wir daraus ein kleines rechteck
formel dann fangen wir schon an das
langsam hier durchzuziehen kraft so und
jetzt werden wir feiern und feiner und
jetzt leute jetzt aufs ganze jetzt
werden daraus nämlich tagliatelle
einmal abschneiden und war so geil aus
bisschen mehr dran und jetzt kommt mein
weg ist flex sagt
jetzt leute kann ich gar nicht mehr groß
auf warum man vielleicht was von meinem
nudelwasser und zwar werde ich jetzt
hier in einer schüssel die eigelbe
hineingeben und den pecorino hinzufügen
und dann leicht einrühren und dann gibt
es vielleicht nur noch einen schritt
machen muss und das ist etwas von
unserem nudelwasser einen guten schluck
übergeben der dann den käse an und
diesen schönen verbindet nehmen uns hier
eine kelle von unserem nudelwasser geben
das jetzt hier hinüber zu unserem
gemisch und früheren es ganz schnell ein
es wird einfach eine cremige konsistenz
und das wichtigste von allem das ist
keine sahen den sieg schnappte nudeln
schnappen gehen wir dazu gehört es musik
in meinen ohren wenn wir jetzt die
frische pasta jetzt wird es zeit dass
wir unsere carbonara soße nehmen und
unter unsere pasta rühren für eine
bewegung bleiben letzter schritt kein
leid aber pfeffer und dann sehen wir es
auch schon gleich beim probieren
[Musik]
klassische carbonara selbst gemachte
nudeln lass dir schmecken mehr kann man
nicht sagen habe ich aber auch schon
kriminell wir sehen muss ich
gleichzeitig auch sagen
klingt aber sehr cremig minimum
so einfach wie passt erster eindruck
war
was sagst du hast sehr sehr lecker
geschmeckt ich fande die cremigkeit
gingen noch besser also ist ähnlichkeit
war so acht und zehn ja ich mag zwar
neun von zehn ja- und insgesamt plus
erfolg war 10.10.10 deswegen insgesamt
würde ich dir für das abendessen heute
für die frische carbonara italienische
art 9,5 punkte geben mal mehr dass die
cremigkeit funktion da dass wir noch
mehr nudelwasser ein bisschen verdünnt
darüber haben wir gesprochen ansonsten
war das wirklich leid und wir haben auch
gesagt das kriegt man nirgendwo so auf
dem teller eric ich danke dir dass du
auch vor der kamera war dabei was ich
hoffe du wirst noch ganz ganz lange
hinter der kamera dabei sind danke
nochmal ein raise hunger für die
unterstützung wir sehen uns beim
nächsten video wieder bis dahin und ciao
ciao